all right so I know what the title says
I wrote it but I honestly don't think
that Diablo 3 sucks then again since I
began to think dozens of hours into it
at launch I've not been inclined to pick
it up again but you can't ignore all the
people on Twitter who are talking about
how much better the game is with its
update and the impending Reaper of souls
so let's talk the lada and how it's
making gobbler three worthwhile again
your first pretty clear indicator the
Diablo 3 is worth your time again is our
glowing review that you can find on
GameSpot which we updated just last week
the changes in gameplay and refinement
from patch 2.0 1 are significant and
impressive one wave Reaper of souls is
set to bring back the awesome is by
making loot matter again with the loot
2.0 not only are the most impressive
items legendaries again but it's also a
little more complicated than just
equipping the sword with bigger numbers
than the other sword as opposed to
classic Diablo 3 gear has a little more
sway on your chosen skills
so for example some items offer up hefty
damage bonuses to certain skills that
make you pay a whole lot more attention
to item details and not just this stat
not only that but you might want to
switch up your skills due to some pretty
exceptional items bringing variation to
your play style you can read more about
that in Cara's article on breathing life
back into Diablo 3 with Reaper of souls
which you can find on GameSpot
next up the auction house is gone and
whilst that's not really the result of
Reaper of souls it should make the
gameplay a done sight better basically
that'll mean all those legendaries
you're picking up and the awesome loot
from my first point our ultra valuable
because the only way you'll be obtaining
this stuff is through your own heroic
efforts and not by sacrificing your bank
account
alright so an awful lot of these do
happen to be about loot but that's
Diablo 3 for you so let's talk the new
adventure mode which coincidentally is
the new best way to get loot really need
someone to give me a dollar every single
time I say that adventure mode is a very
flexible way for you to play solo all
with friends for 15 minutes or hours
you can either pursue quick bounties
that involve slaying this and that from
exclamation point laden NPCs or if you
have some more time do five of those to
access a rift rifts and multi-level
dungeons which take randomness to a
whole new height by mashing up monsters
lighting and tile sets so that all
floors can be totally different as you
expect this then all culminates in a
unique boss fight which is exactly where
you want to be if you're after the
sweetest loot in the game speaking of
random the art of randomness is one of
the best things about Reaper of souls
the introduction of the holy powered
melee fighting Crusader is intriguing
and the promise of an entirely new act
is exciting albeit expected from an
expansion but it's the refinement of
Diablo 3's gameplay elements which will
be the real pull back I'm gonna go out
on a limb and say that this is one of
those games that you're playing for the
combat and the loot chase and not so
much the story I think because of that
one of the best things about Reaper of
souls will be exploring Diablo 3 as a
randomized environment instead of a
predictable world which gets old really
fast and kills off replayability
in act 5 West much now resembles
something of the Elder Scrolls RPGs
because all of these urns are completely
unpredictable is all of this could not
be either and what do you need out of an
RPG to stay interested you can let me
know all of your thoughts
feelings either in that comment section
down below or you can do so on my
Twitter where I'm at Jess McDonald last
week I talked to you guys about my 3ds
and why I reckons that should be your
next console purchase some of you like
Jane Matthews on YouTube completely
agreed with me and said damn she's
absolutely right while others were like
Kaiser Clark who didn't really see the
point in handheld and said why don't we
just play on our mobile phones a lot of
you guys wanted to express your support
for the Vita as your handheld of choice
so fair enough on that one it certainly
does have some cool games then there
were those of you who were thoroughly
convinced by my 3ds pitch but didn't
have the money to go out and buy
yourself one so for those of you who are
in that situation I apologize those are
all the things that I have to say to you
today but be sure to leave me all of
your thoughts in the comments and I'll
catch again next week